are you guys ready to meet the directors
of the DC Universe let's get them out
here right now but they got it all works
out here at Warner Brothers 800 billion
dollar movies like that work from
Suicide Squad David Ayer let's get them
out here from Wonder Woman patty Jenkins
from Justice League Zack Snyder from the
flash Rick ho ye hwa from Aquaman James
Wan and from Batman Ben Affleck let's
give it up for these guys thank you all
for being here David let's start with
you your movie is going to hit the the
big screen first can you tell us about
churning bad guys indie heroes that is
not an easy easy proposition out thing
few words Amanda Waller no it's so you
need more than two words let me think of
something seriously though I I believe
that even the worst of us is capable of
the acts of the greatest good just like
the best of us can do some of the most
terrible things and that's what this
movie is really about it's about people
have been told they're bad their whole
life that discover that they can come
together have a family love each other
and do some amazing good things with
their lives all right patty you've
described Wonder Woman as the movie you
wanted to make your entire life
tell us why Wow it's a combination of
things when I look back on why I'm a
filmmaker in in 1978 when Superman one
came out and I went to go see it that
movie made me have an experience that
I'd never had before where I felt like I
cried for Superman I was Superman I
wanted to be good I wanted to change the
world and I thought that's the most
powerful artistic experience of my life
as a child and then as an adult Wonder
Woman is my favorite Supergirl so the
idea that there had never been an urgent
story done I thought that's like the
greatest to play in this pool of
universal emotions and yet get to do
something so big and beautiful and fun
at the same time the dream come true it
also feels like it's so much of our so
much of the time right now is women
taking charge long overdue
and I think that's a great message of
the movie - yeah I can't believe I feel
so fortunate to be the person here on
this window and it is overdue but it
also feels like the best time in the
world to make this movie so I'm super
psyched
all right Zach you're the first director
to wrangle the biggest DC superheroes in
one movie as a longtime fan how does it
feel to bring all these characters at
the same time to the big screen yeah
it's wow that's well sorry um it's it's
amazing I mean look you know I have I've
been you know blessed with these amazing
actors I have an awesome Batman down
there I have awesome I have awesome
Wonder Woman I have an awesome Superman
and so you know as the rest of the group
kind of comes along to join the
fraternity and I guess now sorority um
they they each have something amazing to
give and you know it is fun as a fan to
just stand there and see them all in
their costumes like looking like you
would hope they look and so for me just
there's plenty of times when we just
were losing it and have been so far but
we'll see some more of that later maybe
all right now Rick
am I correct is this your first time
onstage in Hall H is that right this is
my first time onstage my first time at
comic-con thank you
this is it
pretty nice feeling isn't it this is
that not a bad place to be
yeah many of these people haven't
showered in four days nice to be in an
enclosed space hey and I'm one of them
yes now I am pumped I had to pull out my
flash underoos from back in the day I
know I wasn't the only one I know they
are a bunch of underoos on right now
stubble but yes I'm very excited to be a
part of this DC is the foundation of
what we all know about comic books and
heroes and so they've had great
storytellers great illustrators great
artists great filmmakers to be a part of
that tradition and so to sort of have my
voice be a part of that is really
exciting and to bring flash to to the
screen and for for it in a new way and a
new voices is pretty exciting as well so
I'm just glad to be here and to be on
stage welcome to Hall H yes yeah Justus
Lee James it's fair to call you the
modern-day master of horror now you were
stepping yeah you are stepping into the
world of action superheroes that's a bit
of a change for you how does it feel
it's pretty incredible uh it's funny
I've had a hit I brought a lot of movies
to comic-con but I've never been ho H
before so I'm super excited to be here
with you guys Anna
and I'm more than honored to be up here
on stage with all these amazing
filmmakers so I feel coming amazing
company here oh yeah yes I am um uh
listen I made [ __ ] Aquaman what can I
say ah James Ruby no swearing here oh
sorry these are primarily children oh
come on you should be ashamed of
yourself I were taking you on tonight
yes that sticks Ted out of your sketch
but then is shocked by your language no
I mean Aquaman's such an amazing
character I love the fact that he's
never really been portrayed in the
feature movie whoa before and so and on
the screen of any kind and the the
opportunity to explore this universe you
know bring a bit of my horror element
into this the Dipsy the scary wall and
then also explore the the wondrous
element of Atlantis that's that's all I
have to say very cool very cool
I wanted to have a pool catchphrase -
Aquaman I don't want his catchphrase to
be fish assemble okay work on that Ben
you are already an iconic part of the DC
family but now you're stepping into a
different role in this world as director
how do you feel about that
now honestly I have to say it's kind of
like I've never done this before so
nerdy but I it's such a kind of a big
deal in my life
it's just not going to happen again like
that ever I was kind of a cool moment
for me thanks
I think this very well could happen for
you again oh gosh just may never happen
sigh again the first time never happens
again
go don't yeah this it's really inspiring
you know doing a taking on something
like like this character and the story
is sort of like I think the only thing
analogous to in a drama is like a great
play that has been done a bunch of times
before and so you have the history of
all these incredible artists who have
done it in amazing ways and expectations
of the fans who have seen it invented
and reinvented and reinvented again and
you know magnificently in inspiring ways
so there's a tremendous amount of
pressure and this tremendous amount of
work that's already gone into it it's
terrifying but it's it's inspiring and
it's really really exciting and it's
because it's one of the most iconic and
fascinating characters ever created
certainly in contemporary American drama
and I'm deeply honored and thrilled to
get a chance to do it and to be part of
the DC and Warner Brothers and to be
among these filmmakers here and thank
you for giving me the opportunity hey I
think I speak for all of us these are
really busy people let's all thank these
directors for being here today and
sharing their time with us the DC
directors everybody thank you
thank you
you